got that question what should I do um
when my when n cannot get the technique
going what should I do Dave you're
saying don't shut him down okay I would
say that you can do one of two
things and from there it depends on your
skill even these one of two things it
depends on your skill okay I would say
at a bare minimum if you are somebody
who stilled
my definition of that means that you
have some internal
aspects you generate your own t you can
generate your own tanden just standing
here there's enough yongi and a constant
descent that you can Bounce It Back Off
the Earth and form your own in lower
tonden hence standing meditations hence
Zen there's no UK pushing on you to
generate that y aspect you guys
understand that okay
so I don't need the N to push back on me
to generate my own
tund it's a simple fact you guys
understand that if I can generate it by
myself in a standing
meditation I don't need her to generate
it for me I have generated it here and I
have connected to hers do you see
okay
I do that got it now she's going to move
let's let's stick with the order okay
she's going to move and you can see here
as she goes she does not have my Center
she's in my wrist okay do the same exact
thing again she's in my wrist and you
can see it right there you see
that if you go back and one of the
errors that I said is that you move with
your arm only do you see that so we're
going to for you or do it again look at
my wrist okay now look at her arm and
you see that her arm moves and only her
arm is moving they
say can you see okay so she's not going
to ever move my center but I can put my
Center just like I can put my Center in
this move I can put my Center in any
moves so I move my body and I still have
per
Center do you guys see that I don't stay
here I know the
pattern I keep my Center go back I
engage I find my Center I find her
Center and I move into my Center which
I'm now in her Center okay you feel that
way okay okay she's going to go on I
keep now stay there she's in this
hand little bit earlier take the elbow
hand off I'm in that Center still on
that half watch
Center Center she goes to that Hand
Center you see center now in the two
hands you feel
that so I'm doing
this boom one two both hands she goes
keep my Center same thing stay there
please stay there go stay where you are
engage okay and you can see I'm in her
Center in her Center
and I'm developing her Center as we're
going along she
goes I'm down same thing you're going to
tap or what you going to do it or what
there I have her
Center
down
[Music]
Down Your Righteous helping
UK is going to feel
no
no now
but she didn't learn